le quelque chose ne m'avait pas sauvé
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un souvenir un souvenir un
souvenir de ce que tu as fait à quelqu'un si tu
voles un tableau commençons les enchères
à cinq millions de livres la
politique est un peu musclée
mais aucune œuvre d'art ne vaut un humain
la vie s'arrête là
[Applaudissements]
aucune œuvre d'art ne vaut une vie humaine
[Musique]
où est-ce que tu te souviens as-tu
déjà été hypnotisé avant que tout ce qui est
dans sa tête elle puisse le trouver Je veux que tu
te détendes fils
que peux-tu faire  lui faire n'importe quoi pour toi
courir ensemble elle a mis cette bière
ce n'est pas réel il veut croire que
pourquoi m'as-tu menti ma mémoire est
enfermée dans une cage et j'ai dit aucune force une
serrure ne peut être cassée
j'ai quelque chose à te dire
[  Musique]
Je me souviens